when you think of english-speaking
countries one of the countries that
comes to mind might be new zealand
new zealand is indeed an
english-speaking country but there's
another official language there
one that was there long before the
arrival of english speakers
that language is maori or
the maori language maori is an eastern
polynesian language which belongs to the
wider austronesian language family
it's closely related to hawaiian
hawaiian is part of the markasic branch
of eastern polynesian
and maori is part of the tahitic branch
so it's very similar to the tahitian
language
maori became an official language of new
zealand in 1987
but being an official language doesn't
mean that it's spoken by a large portion
of the population
according to the 2013 census 125 000
people speak maori
or around 21 of the ethnic maori
population
and 3 percent of new zealand's
population but that number seems to
include people with varying degrees of
ability in the language
it's also spoken by around 12 000 maori
immigrants in australia
that's about 8.2 percent of maori
immigrants there
before europeans began to settle there
in the late 1700s
maori was the predominant language
spoken in new zealand on both the
northern and southern islands
and for the first several decades of
settlement many europeans learned maori
but as more traders missionaries and
settlers arrived the number of english
speakers grew
and by the 1860s english speakers began
to outnumber maori speakers
this was partly a result of a major
decline in the maori population
due to diseases introduced by europeans
and the inter-tribal musket wars
beginning in 1867 the native schools act
established a system of primary schools
for maori children
conducted entirely in english this
contributed to the dominance of english
and the decline of maori but most maori
people
still spoke their traditional language
at home until many of them started
migrating to urban areas after the
second world war
a language revival movement gained
momentum in the 1980s and 90s
and in recent years there seems to be
more energy and interest behind revival
efforts once again
we'll look at some basic maori phrases
in a minute but first let's look at a
few features of maori pronunciation and
orthography
there are only 15 letters in the maori
alphabet 8 consonants and 5 vowels
the eight consonants include
and two digraphs no and wh
which is usually pronounced
a voiced bilabial fricative like an f
sound but with your lips touching
there are more variations than this but
these are the most common ones
the small number of consonants in maori
is quite striking when we look at
english loanwords like this one
baby there's no voiced ba
sound in maori so it becomes a voiceless
meaning sheep notice that there's no
sound in maori
so she becomes he the vowels include
and there's one phoneme per letter in
other words maori is written as it
sounds
diphthongs in maori are like vowel
sequences with both vowel sounds
remaining distinct
in other words diphthongs are all
composed of sounds from this list
though there is some variation in how
they're pronounced and for some there's
a generational difference
there's a phonemic distinction between
short vowels and long vowels
and long vowels are normally shown with
a macron for example
goku means shovel while koko
means tui a kind of bird all
syllables end in a vowel for example
meaning man meaning
meaning child there are no consonant
clusters
we can see that in the way this english
loanword is pronounced
for milk notice the extra vowel that's
inserted to break up this consonant
cluster
lk also notice that there's no le sound
in maori so it's pronounced as a
instead let's look at a few basic
phrases
as you see and listen to these phrases
notice the features of maori
pronunciation and orthography that i
talked about in the previous section
hello that's when you say hello to one
person
hello when said to two people
hello one said to three or more people
notice that in maori there's a
distinction between singular dual and
plural
we'll come back to this a little later
good morning
literally peaceful morning specific
greetings for other times of the day
exist
but aren't so commonly used and its dual
and plural forms are normally used
how are you this is the present
continuous aspect marker which expresses
what's happening right now
how you i'm fine
word for word it's present continuous
fine or good
i what's your name
word for word it's specifying particle
who
your name my name is paula
specifying particle paul my name
this word here ko is like a specifying
topic particle
which marks something specific when it
appears as the predicate
please tina thank you when said to one
person
to two people and to three or more
people
or more casually
let's look at the basic word order of
maori
this is a sentence without a verb but it
has a subject and a predicate
notice that the predicate comes first
and the subject comes after it
that's the opposite of the english order
this occurs in many austronesian
languages
including hawaiian and tagalog a
language spoken in the philippines
another example the baby is cute
word for word it's indefinite article
cute the baby
the predicate of this sentence is an
adjective as well as
hey the indefinite article which comes
before an adjective when it serves as a
predicate
this means the cute baby and is not a
full sentence but just a noun phrase
with an adjective
note that the adjective always comes
after the noun in a noun phrase like
this
the basic order in the sentences so far
has been predicate subject
but in sentences with verbs the basic
word order is vso
though there are some exceptions to this
which we might see later
i ate dinner word for word it's past
tense marker
eat i direct object marker the dinner
the word ahau is the first person
singular personal pronoun
the personal pronouns are used as both
subject pronouns and
object pronouns for example in this
sentence
which means she loves me or he loves me
ahau
is the object word for word this
sentence is present continuous marker or
right now
love he or she to me
a moment ago we saw the definite article
this is the singular definite article
the plural definite article is
the person the people note that this
vowel
becomes a long vowel in the plural form
there's also an indefinite article
hey a person the definite articles
basically refer to something specific
and the indefinite article basically
refers to something non-specific
but the articles don't exactly function
the same way they do in english
one difference is that hey is used
before an adjective when it's the
predicate of a sentence
we saw that in this sentence before
meaning the baby is cute notice that hey
comes before the adjective
also in many cases hay is not used and a
different determiner is used instead
it's a determiner which means ah or one
or a certain
something for plural nouns
we're going to see a movie word for word
it's non-past marker
c we direct object marker a
movie let's also look at the
demonstrative adjectives or
demonstrative pronouns which have a
three-way distinction in location
this dna dna
this book that when something is near
the listener
that book near the listener that when
something is away from both the speaker
and the listener
that book when it's away from both
people for the plural forms you simply
drop the t
at the beginning of the word these
these books those near the listener
those books near the listener those away
from both the speaker and the listener
those books over there
that is julia's book over there word for
word it's
specific particle definite article book
possessive particle
julia over there here's the
demonstrative pronoun
is the specifying particle we saw before
it's often used in equational sentences
with no verb
possessives ah is a particle that shows
possession
the possessor hurya comes after it and
the thing that's possessed
comes before it ah is one form of the
possessive particle
but it can also be o it depends on the
nature of the possession
ah is used when you can choose whether
you possess it or not
or you're dominant over it like a parent
possesses a child
those are a-class possessives
julia's book or is used when you can't
choose whether you possess it or not
or you are subordinate to the object
like a child possesses a parent these
are o-class possessives
for example julia's nose
julia can't really decide whether she
possesses her nose or not
these possessives have additional
alternate forms
in the plural the t is dropped
these possessive particles are also
added to the plural
and dual personal pronouns to form the
plural and dual possessive adjectives or
possessive pronouns
for example our book
inclusive our book
exclusive notice that in maori there's a
distinction between the first person
plural inclusive
which includes the listener and
exclusive which excludes the listener
and the dual possessive adjectives and
pronouns are formed in the same way
for example this means our book
inclusive but in this case our means
belonging to the two of us
because it's dual the singular
possessives
don't have the particles we saw above
but they do have
a class and o class forms as well as
neutral forms
for example means my book
when a possessive comes before a noun
the neutral form can optionally be used
instead of the a
form or o form now let's focus a little
bit on
verbs in maori there's no verb meaning
to be
we can see this in the sentence we saw
earlier
the baby is cute the pattern is simply
predicate subject
another important thing to point out is
that verbs in maori are not
conjugated for person and number the
verb form doesn't change regardless of
the subject
they sleep and so on on top of that
the verbs themselves are not conjugated
for tense
instead there are verbal particles
mostly before the verb that indicate
time aspect or mood you can see one
example of those verbal particles in
these sentences here
e this represents past tense
i learned for past continuous
i was learning for present continuous
i'm learning for perfect aspect
i have learned or i had learned notice
that this doesn't tell us the tense of
the verb but that the action has been
completed
this is used for non-past in other words
the general present tense or the future
and the inceptive form inceptive means
it shows the beginning of an action
i learn or i'll learn
this indicates the imperfect or
continuous aspect
i'm learning and so on now let's look at
a couple more sentences and break them
down
this means we don't live in the city we
live in the countryside
word for word it's not we exclusive
imperfect live in the town big
in the countryside we exclusive
imperfect live first we see the negation
word
there are a few different negation words
depending on the type of sentence
but this is the most common one with a
verb in an indicative sentence
here it's followed by the first person
plural exclusive pronoun
meaning that it excludes the listener
here we see one of the verbal particles
or
verbal particle units that we saw a few
moments ago here it expresses the
imperfect
to indicate that a state is still
ongoing notice that this is a particle
with two components which
are split by the verb which means live
is a preposition meaning at or in and
the phrase
means the big town but notice again that
the adjective comes after the noun
remember before when i said that maori
is generally vso or predicate subject
well in a sentence like this with a
negative the word order changes
after the negation word the subject
comes before the verb
notice that the second sentence begins
with
a phrase showing location whereas the
phrase showing location in the first
sentence comes at the end
this phrase appears at the beginning of
the sentence to place emphasis on it
as you can see maori is for the most
part a straightforward language
as well as a fun language to delve into
but it does remain an endangered
language
in recent years there have been
inspiring attempts to promote and
revitalize the language
and those efforts continue today in fact
the current prime minister of new
zealand
is aiming for 1 million new maori
speakers by the year 2040.
she also intends to raise her daughter
to be bilingual in
english and maori and several elements
of the education system aim to increase
the number of fluent maori speakers
one element is kohangareo which
literally means
language nest this is a type of early
childhood education facility where the
children are immersed in maori language
and culture
there are also maori immersion schools
and bilingual schools
but only a minority of maori students
study in these schools
around 20 percent at the kohangareo
level and 10 percent in primary and
secondary schools
whether or not maori can be successfully
revitalized really depends on enrollment
in these programs
as a lover of languages i really hope
that the maori language will survive and
thrive the question of the day if you're
of maori origin
how much of the maori language do you
know in what situations do you use it
and for other people are there any
similarly endangered languages in your
country
are there any efforts to revitalize them
leave your answers in the comments down
below
and it's time to give special thanks to
all of the langfocus patreon supporters
who make it much easier to keep this
channel going month after month
i especially want to thank the ones
whose names appear right here on the
screen because they are the top tier
patreon supporters so many extra special
thanks go out to them
and everyone thank you for watching and
see ya
[Music]
you